now in the last few minutes dup mps and
assembly members have formally endorsed
sir jeffrey donaldson to become the
party's new leader
it follows that she mulches two months
for the party after successive revolts
deposed
arlene foster and edwin putz who was in
a job for just
21 days well sir jeffrey who's the dop's
leader in westminster was the only
candidate to put his name forward
to succeed mr poot well i'm now joined
by
mick filthy editor of these slugger
o'toole news website
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on sky news this afternoon
so three leaders in two months can this
one survive
well i think only from the point of view
that through trial and error
they've tried all the other options uh
they tried sticking by arlene foster
uh but actually the political conditions
around the protocol
a certain degree of first of all backing
it and then backing
away from it and saying no no no but
eventually her situation became
untenable
uh the party split right down the middle
and probably the less capable of two uh
men uh took over and i think now they've
had
really two to three weeks of complete
embarrassment
at being seen to be split and this is
one thing that the dup
had never really had to experience
before so
i think really nine you can tell from
the voting numbers that
most of them realize that they really
don't have a choice here they've really
got the back
donaldson absolutely to the hilt or
at the next assembly election next year
um if they don't stick together they
will hang apart
so as a new era then of course with a
new leader in charge now coming in can
we expect any change
of party policy particularly around the
northern ireland protocol
well i think what we'll see not so much
as a change in policy
but certainly a dampening of some of the
cataclysmic
rhetoric that some some members of the
dup have been using
this idea that they're going to get rid
of the protocol well they're not in a
position to do that that is
entirely up to the uk government and in
its negotiations with the european union
but even it puts edwin coats who was
you know so recently the post has
accepted even
in his own kind of uh sort of departing
remarks
that instead of opposing uh the protocol
really what they have to do is focus on
getting uh improvements to it and you
know he was fairly
positive and upbeat in his remarks uh
that that there has been some
um progress he thinks with the uk
government but of course it isn't
entirely down to the united kingdom
government it is down to those
negotiations uh through the joint
committee
so edwin putz then now he was ousted
after just
um as i was saying earlier 21 days for
committing to power sharing without
movement on the protocol so i think the
question here is
can power sharing survive if the irish
sea border
remains that's a good question
uh you know the good friday agreement
has had a very stormy
history um it took 18 months
before between the first assembly
election and the assembly actually
sitting
and in those occasions it was really all
to do with the fact that the ira refused
to commit to any kind of timetable to
get rid of its guns
and we've seen breakdowns with spy rings
being discovered in storm up and we've
seen
uh the breakdown over the rhi
back in 2017 but really i think
we're getting to a point now there's
been a generation since the good friday
agreement
and i think there's a new class of
politician coming through
both from the middle the alliance party
under naomi
long but also uh the nationalists under
uh the sdlp column eastwood
um start to chart a new brand of
politics and i think
if these two parties and i think the dup
and champion have been complicit
in using the institutions uh to further
their own agendas or to stop
the others agenda i i think if they keep
playing that game uh they'll
they will lose the dominant plays that
they've uh that they've held for most of
the last 20 years
now the protocol is an international
treaty
so what can uk government do to reassure
unionists and secure devolved government
well really what they need to do is to
work on all the things that they've been
managing through uh by the extension of
these
grace periods there's uh any all it's
all pretty technical to be honest
vanessa none of this is really
massive big politics which is part of
the puzzle as to why the dup is allowed
to get out of control
um but really what it needs to do is the
east-west there's no problem uh anything
made in northern ireland that
can come into britain without any
difficulty whatsoever there's no red
tape there's no
it's when it comes from britain into
northern ireland
uh that that the non-tariff barriers if
you like the regulation
demanded by the european union for for
trial you know trade
coming from east to west as long as
there are a set of fixes that really
take the tension down on that then i
think
everyone can kind of get back to
business as normal
because the opportunity the opportunity
for northern ireland
is enormous um it has
not only access into the rest of britain
in terms of
exporting from northern ireland into
britain it also has
privileged access its fishermen its uh
farmers etc have
privileged access not just in the
republic in the south of the island but
deep into the european union that
massive um
uh uh market that's now not
denied to the united kingdom the rest of
the united kingdom but certainly
is more difficult so the prize of
getting this right
for northern ireland is absolutely
enormous